en este vídeo vamos a introducir la idea
de sumar decimales y los animó a que
pulsen el vídeo y piensen en esto antes
de que lo resolvamos juntos vamos a
trabajar lentamente y en futuros vídeos
vamos a descubrir formas más rápidas de
resolverlo pero la manera en que lo
vamos a aprender en este vídeo es para
asegurarnos de que entendemos lo que
está pasando así que digamos que
queremos sumar 0.1 + 0.8 o podríamos
decir que estamos sumando un décimo más
8 decimos pausa este vídeo y trata de
resolverlo existe un par de formas para
pensar en esto podrías decir que es 0.1
es un décimo y 0.8 es igual a 8 decimos
y tengo uno de algo y le sumó ocho de
ese algo en este caso tengo un décimo y
le sumó ocho décimos voy a terminar con
nueve de ese algo que en este caso son
décimos esto es igual a nueve décimos es
una manera de pensar en esto y podemos
hacerlo también de forma visual vamos a
tomar un entero y lo tenemos dividido en
décimos
este es un entero dividido en diez
secciones iguales así que podemos ver
cada una de estas secciones blancas como
un décimo entonces aquí tenemos un
décimo y lo voy a colorear y a esto le
queremos agregar ocho decimos 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 así que cuántos décimos tenemos en
total vamos a contar los 12
456 789 esto en realidad nos está
mostrando lo mismo todo esto es igual a
9 decimos y como escribimos 9 decimos en
forma decimal bueno pues vamos a la
posición de los decimos que es el primer
espacio a la derecha del punto y tenemos
9 decimos esta es la posición de los
décimos
el resultado es entonces 9 de éstos
decimos que tenemos aquí
así que continuemos hagamos otro ejemplo
digamos que tenemos tres décimos y le
queremos sumar nueve décimos a que va a
ser igual podemos usar la misma idea si
decimos que estos son tres décimos y le
vamos a sumar nueve décimos bueno si
tengo tres de algo y le sumo 9 de lo
mismo el resultado va a ser 12 39 es
igual a 12 y podríamos decir que esto es
igual a 12 decimos ahora esto podría ser
un poco extraño que significa 12 decimos
bueno una manera de pensar en esto es 10
decimos más dos décimos ya que es igual
10 decimos bueno si tenemos 10 décimos
es igual a un entero así que esto es
igual a 1
aquí tenemos 1 y 2 decimos y como
escribimos 1 y 2 decimos bueno en la
posición de las unidades escribimos 1 y
en la posición de los décimos escribimos
nuestros dos décimos así que podemos
decir que esto es igual a 1.2
es igual a 1 y 2 decimos y esto es igual
a 12 decimos ahora si lo queremos
resolver visualmente vamos a nuestro
diagrama una vez más en realidad voy a
poner aquí dos de estos un entero y otro
entero y queremos sumar vamos a empezar
por los tres décimos y los voy a
colorear rápidamente con azul claro este
es uno dos y tres y le vamos a sumar
nueve decimos 1
8 y 9 aquí lo tenemos 9 decimos colorea
mos 9 decimos en amarillo y tenemos 3
decimos en azul qué pasa si los juntamos
todos bueno tenemos 3 decimos más 7
decimos aquí que hacen un entero este es
nuestro 1 y tenemos otros dos decimos
este es nuestro 0.2 o nuestros 2 decimos
entonces tenemos 1 + 0.2 que es igual a
1.2 así que espero que esto les dé una
idea de cómo hacemos para sumar
decimales y aunque en el futuro vamos a
descubrir formas más rápidas de hacerlo
o formas más sistemáticas de hacerlo
esta es la forma en que lo hago en mi
cabeza si alguien se acerca en la calle
y me dice oye cuánto es 0.3 0.9 así es
como lo pienso